foreign
[Music]
place in my marriage where I'm half and
half out is it possible to fall back in
love with your spouse
off the top of my head I'm going to say
no I think you should move out
[Music]
yo yo yo what's up this is John with the
Dr John deloney show
so glad that you're with us
hanging out listening to the greatest
mental health and marriage and parenting
podcast ever
um Hey My My experiment is for sure
working so I was like six months ago
um I was reading about some journalism
tips and tricks right some things that
journalists do that politicians do
um
so that they can gain advantage and one
of the things one of the core tenets is
to just flood the field with garbage
say everything's the greatest
everything's the worst thing ever this
is the most worst ever just just make a
bunch of outlandish statements
and initially people roll their eyes
like oh my gosh this person's ridiculous
or [__] or whatever
and then in short order
people start either a completely
disregarding everything you say which
then allows you to
um move about the cabin without any
interference you can just do whatever
you want because no one's listening
anymore or you slowly start to move the
dial
right so think about it when your kid
says that's the best movie ever it's the
best movie ever and then you watch it
you're like this is terrible in the next
movie like this is the best movie ever
you either a quit listening to their
advice or you find yourself like five or
ten years later kind of defending the
movie so I tell you all that to tell you
I just started trying it on the show I
just started opening every show by
saying this is the greatest mental
health podcast ever it's for sure not
not even close maybe top 1000 and
there's a lot of podcasts out there
um I bet we're top 900 I would give us
top nine you think Kelly you think we're
top 90 I think we're top 900. I think
more I think we're better than that
well of course you do you have a better
disposition on the world than a better
outlook on life it's also it's like my
job that is your job we are we we are
top 400 we are top 400 I think
um
but the number of people over the last
six months the number of media
conversations the number of people slide
into the old DMs who talk about this as
the greatest show ever
it's incredible so listen
um just uh some some friendly wisdom
from from Uncle John
just start saying everything's the
greatest of all time eventually people
will people will believe you or they'll
just tune out and that's fine all right
let's go to teen oh oh oh real quick
the one and only I didn't ask permission
to use her name so her online handle is
des crane
Miss crane listen uh she sent us a bunch
of the whole team care packages with
chocolates and yetis and hydration and
tea these Fancy Pants teas that thank
you so so much for caring about us for
everybody in there man it's awesome
right yes thank you thank you I'll tell
you what man thank you so much for for
thinking about us
um it's awesome all right let's go to
Tina in chai town in Chicago what's up
Tina
hey John how we doing glad to be talking
to you today I'm glad to be talking to
you what's up I could I could really use
your advice maybe maybe
so for the last uh six months or so I've
been living in this in between place in
my marriage where I'm half and half out
I feel stuck unable to move forward and
it's taking a big toll on me so my
question for you today
is it possible to fall back in love with
your spouse
and I can give you some background
off the top of my head I'm going to say
no I think you should move out
okay now I just said that to be
provocative when I said that you kind of
smiled and laughed
how did you feel when I said that
I figured you were joking okay well
there we go I'm not very good at this
job so normally when somebody tells me
they're stuck
I will do my best to convince them right
off the bat that one answer is the right
one
because usually it's like setting a
puzzle piece in and you know if it fits
or not and so
um or you will push back and immediately
start to fight me like no I'm in this
mirror right so it becomes something
very powerful
um why
why have you and I'm I'm intentionally
using these words why are you choosing
to be stuck
that's a good question maybe if I give
my background it might help just
Enlighten to what's going on so
we've been married for almost five years
together for seven we have two kids a
stepchild and one together
shortly after we got married I realized
how much anxiety and alcohol consumed my
husband
when I was pregnant and after our son
was born it got worse and I became the
default parent it's been really hard
after many failed attempts to get his
addiction under control I hit my
breaking point last fall but I wasn't
really ready to move out and I gave
myself until the end of the year
in November I finally told him that I
would not keep living like this
and he said he heard me differently than
all of the other times before and he's
been showing consistent real change for
the past four to five weeks
so for so long I visualized My Life as a
single parent without him because I
didn't see him changing and making some
of the strides that he has been more
recently I just know that it feels like
I don't have the same feelings as he
does for me anymore and I feel stuck in
deciding like can I jump back into this
or is it time to
move on kind of without him yeah I mean
you left him
you left him a while ago
and
you waited for a while to tell him and
you told him in the form of a
if-then statement if you don't do this
then I'm gonna fill in the blank
and he called your bluff
and now you're in a mess right
it feels like the more honest thing
would have been just in November
actually back in June back in
uh March
to say I can't be in a marriage I I feel
unsafe
because you are an alcoholic I feel
unsafe because you're not taking care of
yourself
um I'm out
that would that would have been the most
honest way or to say I am considering
leaving you because I don't feel safe
sure
and does not happen though so here we
are so it sounds to me like you left now
you chose to
withdrawal
and so I think one million percent you
can choose to hop back in
he's at the very very very beginning
stages of sobriety
and when somebody tells me someone's
struggling with alcohol and anxiety
that's I I immediately go to
a connection issue relationship issues
probably stemming from a long long time
ago
and you tell me they escalate
um when you had a kid
especially first kid is when most
couples report an a
significant reduction in
connectivity intimacy and of course you
have another human that suddenly
figuring out how to take care of right
and so that is a that isn't that isn't
surprise me at all that he got more
anxious because his body felt more
disconnected alone and he drank more to
shut up the anxiety alarms like that
doesn't that it bothers me it's not a
great uh response but it makes perfect
sense
and so the question you have to ask
yourself is are
you willing to
quit being in the middle here go all in
on this marriage
ask him how can I help meet your needs
and you probably for the first time
commit to being honest on a regular
ongoing basis about what you need
if you're willing to do that man I think
you can get there if you have left the
relationship though don't be cruel to
him don't be cruel to yourself don't be
cruel to your kids
um
make your adult decision and then live
with the adult consequences and move on
about your day
it's been hard because like I said the
field attempts
it'll be okay for a while and he'll try
really hard and I'll believe okay this
time is different and so I do I have
like re-engaged come back in and then
inevitably it goes off the rails again
and it's just kind of that consistent
and I just feel like it's kind of beat
into me that
you know it's a pattern and so it's also
hard to figure out you know is this
consistent change that seems very real
to me he says it feels different
more recently is like how do I move past
you know some of the fears that I have
that this is just another like failed
attempt and that's really kind of where
I care a lot less about feelings right
now
I don't care how he feels
I care what he's doing
and
you need to feel your bodies trying to
get your attention saying hey we've been
down this road we hurt every time your
body's doing exactly what it's supposed
to be doing
you just have to decide I hear you I
hear you and this has gotten us hurt
before
but I'm going to choose to be vulnerable
and go all in one more time
or
you're right it's time for us to get out
of here
because you the one thing I know for
certain is your relationship will end if
you've got one foot in and one foot out
and it will end catastrophically or in a
huge mess and you end up in a weird way
becoming the bad guy
right
and so I would tell you to be a be a
person of integrity and I don't mean
that in a like to be throwing grenades
at you but be in or be out and if you're
in
say every time this gets me hurt every
time this drags me through the mud
um you hurt me you drag me through the
mud
and I'm choosing to go all in again and
here's what this is going to look like
have you outlined not what he needs to
be doing but have you outlined what you
need to be whole in this marriage
yes we've had a conversation multiple
times I mean more recently was probably
a couple months ago but when I did tell
him that I wouldn't keep living like
this like he referenced like some of the
things that I had shared before so he
knows what they are okay what is he
doing to get sober
and stay sober
so he weekly has been working with a
counselor that
specializes in addiction and
is helping like through his anxiety and
past traumas and things like that
we've been going
um it's been sporadic but we go to the
same counselor that he sees individually
together
um but more specifically like things
that he's been doing and like he has not
been putting himself in Temptation uh
meaning like going to the bars
um unless it's for a specific thing or
he has specific kind of goals in mind
top of mind he
he's catching himself a lot more instead
of like reacting in a normal way he's
taking the time to like really think
about it be conscious
um so I see that he's doing like the
internal work in addition to like I said
working with his counselor so you
mentioned a bunch and those are five
things the fine things especially
getting professional help
um my in a perfect world he'd be going
to a group three or four times a week
especially here at the beginning
um but I'll leave that between him and
his counselor
um
you named a bunch of things that he is
stopping doing
he's stopping being reactive he's
stopping going to the bars he's stopping
filling the blank that's all fine and
good
the only way I believe this is
sustainable is if you two decide some
things you're going to do together that
you're that are going to replace some of
those things he doesn't go to the bar
you all have a weekly night that y'all
put the kids to bed and you both stay up
30 minutes later and you just hang out
you play questions for humans you are
silly you all make out like you used to
when you were dating like whatever
things you play dominoes I don't care
what you're doing you watch now I would
rather you not watch a show together
because that can just be numbing too but
watch a show together if that's what you
got to do so I would love we're gonna go
for walks together we're gonna go to the
gym together we are going to have one
couple or one group of friends over to
our house every week we're gonna make
ourselves do it even when the house is a
wreck and we're tired we're gonna figure
this out because we're going to start
not only stop doing things that hurt us
but we're going to start adding things
doing things participating in a way of
life that makes the whole environment
less anxious
and that's connectivity that's free
we're going to pay our debts off we're
going to find those things that make us
anxious
we're going to get rid of a bunch of
clutter and a bunch of crap you see what
I'm saying so we're gonna we're gonna do
positive things too and that's where you
can not just sit on the sidelines with
your arms folded judging him to see if
he's making progress but this is where
you are vulnerable and you participate
in what happens next
you become you'll you'll begin to
you're building a new life together a
non-anxious life together
so
to answer your original question do I
think you can fall back in love
absolutely I do
um
do I will I ever know the ins and outs
of the abuse you've experienced and oh
no I don't and so only you can make that
call
um
just because I think you can doesn't
mean it's gonna happen is it maybe a
better way to phrase it is is it
possible yes likely I I don't know
what I do know is if you're gonna stay
in it you gotta be all in and being all
in means you gotta be vulnerable and
being vulnerable means you might get
hurt again
it's the only way love works
I hate it I don't like the design I wish
I could be kind of in and kind of you
can't
and on the other side if you're going to
be I'll be all the way out don't torture
him don't torture you don't drag those
kids through it if you're out be out
and as long as you're in
um this relationship moving forward
never wait one month five months nine
months to communicate
your needs
love yourself enough to be heard on a
daily basis on a weekly basis because
your needs matter
let me know what you decide I'm
interested to see where this thing heads
and I'll be here if you need anything
further we'll be right back
hey deloney here and I've got word from
this episode's sponsor betterhelp hey
look there's a lot of things we don't
get to choose on this wild ride called
life right the neighbor's kid learning
to play Trombone weird things trending
on the tick tocks or whatever that is we
don't get to choose the weather but when
you realize how much you do have a
choice in it's so empowering check this
out you get to decide who you want to be
I get to ask myself the question who do
I want to be you get to choose who
speaks into your life and you get to
choose to pursue meaningful
relationships this is life-changing
stuff but I'll be honest it's not easy
these are new skills that we all have to
learn and therapy is a great place to
practice these new skills and that's why
I love better help better help is
Affordable online therapy that can match
you with a therapist quickly and it lets
you switch any time to make sure it's
the right fit and just like in-person
therapy it can help equip you with the
tools you need to work towards being who
you want to be because you don't just
have to let life happen happen to you
you can take it head on so visit
betterhelp.com deloney today to get 10
off your first month that's better help
h-e-l-p.com slash deloni
all right let's go to Zach in Huntsville
Texas what's up Zach
not much just uh trying to get out of
this ice storm yeah welcome to it man
welcome to welcome to Texas welcome to
Texas
it's cold once a year when it is ice
falls from the sky
I know right so what's up dude
uh nothing good unfortunately oh man
tell me about it
okay
um uh the question is basically we need
to know what boundaries or how to set
boundaries or whatever the case may be
with a friend who is in an abusive
relationship
Define abuse for me
um I'll give you examples if you need to
but uh
to cover it all he's
he's verbally abusive he is neglectful
of her and their infant child
they got one daughter that's living with
his grandparents because he's too big of
a stand up to his grandmother and tell
her no the kid's gonna come stay home
with me even though there's no custody
of the arrangement whatsoever
we have have to constantly help her out
because he won't like um like I'll give
this one example
um a week after their infant daughter
was born she calls me and asked me to
take her to her one-week checkup and her
quote was
he doesn't want to
they recently they spent a uh her and
her daughter spent a week in the
hospital they checked her the baby in
for observations because she had gone to
the ER because the baby hasn't gained
much weight
and he didn't show up for a single day
that they were in the hospital we took
her there and we took her home
and we're at the point where like I
I value marriage about as much as you
and Dave do but we're at the point we're
no longer supporting them being together
we're telling her if you call us with
any problems we're going to tell you to
just leave him because we're getting
sick of it
she seems to somewhat be on board with
the idea of leaving him but she is
terrified of the idea of going to a
shelter which is the last thing I told
her she needed to do
and
at this point I'm getting it at this
point we're trying to figure out how to
protect our family and set boundaries
and stuff up so that
we don't have to keep being stressed out
by the constant neglect and abuse that
is coming with this but at the same time
we don't want to abandon her because we
know that that's just gonna leave for no
choice but to stay there because my
me and my roommates were literally all
she's got
what I'm going to tell you is hard okay
because you go to great heart and I wish
there were more people who cared about
hurting people in the world
but at the end of the day
you can't make her do anything
you can call and I would recommend you
call the authorities because
[Music]
um
uh for because if the kids are being
abused to be neglected if they're being
left alone
but at the end of the day the fact that
she hasn't
called 9-1-1 screaming
bloody murder that some old woman has
taken her baby that's her choice blame a
husband all you want
the fact that she doesn't want to live
in a shelter totally get that she hasn't
come to you and said I need a place to
stay for 60 or 90 days will you help me
she hasn't done that
and so one of the most difficult
challenging things is being in a
relationship with other adults
because we can't make them do the things
that we can just so clearly see
would help them be safe and whole you
throw kids in the mix and it's it's even
worse
what is uh do you know this guy would
have stopped you from calling this guy
he
um I'm not 100 confident in my ability
to defend myself and he can get pretty
violent for example like another reason
why I can't stand this I
I got up four in the morning I did my
delivery I was going home I went to
Walmart because we were preparing for
Halloween or something with some or
other and then
I get a call asking to take her to the
ER because she's got a prolapsed uterus
I go over there
that he initially called me because he
didn't think his car would make the 30
mile trip South down to the ER
I go over there and he's sitting in his
car screwing with it I go inside she's
getting the baby and all the stuff ready
for it and I swear to God I've never
been closer to punching him in my life I
got them and everybody ready to go he
sat down and ate pizza
and I
why have you made this this your War
I like you wake up every day and raised
and you go to bed every day enraged and
you spin out and you spin out and you
spin out and she hasn't asked for your
help
or when she does she just wants a ride
and you give her that ride and you give
her advice you say I think you should
leave and she goes I know and then she
doesn't
at some point you're continuing to
torture yourself because this guy is a
terrible human being and make no mistake
he sounds like a terrible human being
an absolute terrible human being
on all counts
but your daily choice to just Swan Dive
into that cesspool
is you choosing to make your life
shorter you're going to have a stroke
and you're gonna have a heart he doesn't
think about you every day you think
about him a lot
yep it's mostly because like I'll have a
pretty good day and then she'll text me
and be like hey I need this or this or
this because
I'm not getting it
and I I will admit I'm very close to
just calling it I'm what's torturing me
is I don't know how to tell her we can't
participate in this any longer without
getting her making her think that when
she finally gets sick of it we're not
going to be there to help I want to make
sure exactly like you just said it
you take her out for coffee you and a
couple other guys that way she doesn't
believe this is some sort of romantic
move on your part and you'd be surprised
at how signals get crossed when people
are in these kind of situations
and you tell her very clearly we cannot
be your fallback plan
24 hours a day 365 days a year
we love you and we are scared to death
for you and we're scared of those kids
but you're an adult and you're making
adult choices
the moment you're ready to leave our
front door is open for you
but until then you're gonna have to make
some grown-up choices
if this is the life you are choosing
this is the mayor and I and let me let
me be honest
it makes me sick to my stomach to say
that because I don't think she's
consciously choosing this I think she's
absolutely feels stuck and trapped this
may have been the world she grew up with
who knows they may be threatened to keep
her baby to make up all kinds of stuff
she may have an addiction that you know
nothing about who like there's a million
different variables here
I've seen it all and then I know I
haven't seen any of it okay
you can't control any of those things
you can only control you
and so I think you are very very honest
and clear about your boundaries
um
I do want to ask one thing just because
this is the only really this is the
biggest worry about if it comes to the
point where we're her only option we
take her in our house would it be wrong
for me to or is there a better way to
say we're not taking you in unless
you're leaving him
I mean you could say whatever you want
no I I I know that the only reason I
haven't said that yet is because I don't
know if that's the right thing to help
her or if it's
I I mean it would be foolish of me to
weigh in on that because I don't know
like you you get to put the boundaries
and stipulations it's like when somebody
donates five thousand dollars and say
you have to spend it like this this and
this I may say that's ridiculous it
doesn't matter what I think it's their
money I can either choose to take it or
not take it
and the moment she moved she says I'm
come get me I need to get out of here
he's at work you
um she needs to call and have a
restraining order put on
so he didn't show up at your front door
and by choosing to get involved you're
choosing to
potentially Put Yourself In Harm's Way
it's not by your hand but in your lap
you didn't ask for this it came to you
and you're the kind of guy that steps in
the middle in the gap
and so I'll tell you to be wise and
don't be a hero and this isn't a movie
set
so call the local authorities and make
sure she's got the resources that she
needs Beyond you can give her a place to
stay
that's safe for her and her kids you
cannot do trauma therapy
and you cannot do job placement service
like she's gonna need some professional
help significant professional help
you're not an attorney that's going to
help her get full custody of her kids
but it's telling to me
that Grandma took the baby
and she hasn't burned people's house
down if somebody takes my daughter I
don't care who they are
it's gonna be a bad bad day and I'm a
pretty chill guy
and Kevin help what my wife would do
see what I'm saying like there's a
there's a clearly another side to this
what I will promise you is if you walk
around bathing in Rage
you're not going to make wise choices
if you wake up every day with a single
fixation on this guy it's saving this
woman and
finally coming up with the right thing
so that she may
you're gonna end up getting yourself
hurt
it's I think what you and your roommates
need to do is come up with some sort of
guys let's all sit down let's spend half
an hour on this and let's ride out on a
piece of paper all gonna agree here's
the here's our boundaries on this deal
and then all three of y'all all four of
you how many roommates you got y'all all
go out to IHOP and you take her with you
go to Waffle House take her with you and
you say hey worried about you you know
that
we love helping you we love loving you
but we can't participate in this any
longer
the moment you're ready to leave we'll
come get you
and if you want to say but it's got to
be for good fine I think the last number
I read was people go back six or seven
times I think five or six or seven times
I go back to abusive relationships
um
so may not last long but such it is you
can put whatever stipulations you want
the last thing she needs is some other
person to come in and take her life from
her
she needs to be given a context of
Safety and Security so she can make the
hard choices on her own
thank you for stepping up man thank you
for stepping up
[Music]
but knowing what you can control versus
what you can't control that's one of the
cornerstones of a healthy life
and unfortunately we all control very
very little
but we do control our ability to love so
thank you for stepping in the Gap let me
know how it goes man we'll be right back
hey good folks John deloney here I I
fell through a glitch in The Matrix this
is my job I get to have this show do
this show walk alongside each one of you
as a career this is what I do and I have
a blast doing it and me and the team
were so thankful for all of you for
being a part of our show whether you're
one of the original 17 or you're one of
the millions that's come since then we
are so grateful for you and we want to
put together the best possible show that
we can so if you're one of The Originals
or if you're brand new we want your
feedback tell us what you love about the
show what you hate about the show would
you like to see more of what you like to
hear more of and what you want us to
never do again you can email us at
askjohn ramseysolutions.com that's ask
John
ramseysolutions.com with your feedback
thank you for being such an important
part of this show rock on
all right we're back
guess what time it is kids
it's time
man get your bandanas out it's time
for facts of your friends
oh man I'm looking at like I set it up
like it's
today's facts your friends I'm us gonna
say at the outset this one's tough
because I'm Gonna Leave You with some
some concrete steps some concrete things
to look for
but I also I'm Gonna Leave You with some
open-handed open-ended discussion topics
um because
I'll be honest I struggle with this and
I should it's one of those things that
like as somebody who spent their years
working with abused and traumatized
people I should be able to Rattle this
off and I've called some of my
colleagues across the country I have sat
on the internets I've read books I
really struggle with a definition
of the word abuse
and when you say that's abuse we all
know what that is right it's it's
physical abuse it's harm it's somebody
hurting you it's psychological abuse
it's sexual abuse it's neglect right we
know
when we hear the word abuse it it's easy
to think like I know when I see it right
like that old court case about
pornography I know it when I see it
right
but as a science nerd it's just a nerd
in general that's not good enough I like
to Define it what is it and so I can
just a simple definition online I I this
is just a random place I just typed into
the Google's what is abuse and here's
the definition abuse is defined as any
action that intentionally harms or
injures another person that makes sense
right so some of my discussions with my
colleagues was
yeah it's it's an intent to harm it's an
action that that intends to hurt
somebody
the reason why I balk at that is neglect
is also abuse
like the last caller we had a dad just
sitting around while his kid needs to go
to the ER and he's just not paying
attention he's just eating chips he's
not trying to hurt that kid he couldn't
care less about that kid
that's abuse
and so there's no intent there
there's just neglect there's just
complete disregard and I would suggest
that still abuse and here's another
um challenge
um I had a colleague once that was we
were all having a meeting and the
meeting got got tense but we were all it
was a tense meeting we were also
laughing back and forth and the boss
said something right like the the
highest ranking person in the room said
something
and everybody's laughing
it was like a very passive quiet just
silly throwaway thing and it wasn't an
insult it wasn't a anything derogatory
it was just like ah
a little while later my colleague came
out of that meeting and she was rage
crying
rage crying
she was shaking to her core
and the way she explained it was this
incredibly abusive Behavior by the boss
I was there
everybody was there men and women
and nobody saw it
in fact we all saw the opposite we all
saw some attempts to kind of let the air
out of the room and to connect
and I think it would be dismissive to
suggest that her body was not in full
fight or flight her body had moved to
defend itself
to to run
to freeze to come back swinging
and so for me in my chair to be like ah
it's not abuse
I don't like that either
doesn't feel right and if we create a
culture where the end user the end
receiver is the person who defines abuse
yeah get the world we got now
where everybody's offended about
everything
and
you know one of the cornerstones of
anxiety is you got to go through it you
got to work you got to head right into
the middle of the storm that's where
healing is
but we've created a culture where
everybody's anxious about everything
everybody's fired up and worried about
everything and it's everybody else's job
in the world to bend their lives around
our offense or our discomfort
and it's chaos it's Madness it's a
moving Target so I don't like saying
that every person gets to Define abuse
for themselves that doesn't make sense
so I find myself in this quandary
I like the idea of abuse is harm right
it's a harm whether you meant it or not
I also think there's got to be some sort
of boundary there
otherwise you get into this these
thought crimes in this
you raised an eyebrow and all of a
sudden it hurt like it's just such a
mess
and so I leave that to you I think it's
an important topic to discuss how do we
Define abuse at the end of the day
um
I even have to go this far as I'm you
know I want you guys to see our guest
experience that's annoying my wife tells
me I'm I try to think through an
argument in my mind and get all the way
to the end of the argument
um
I can also Imagine a scenario where
certain Behavior would be unifying in
one situation and abusive in another
right so it may be
um fun it may be unifying to poke to
make jokes with some of my childhood
friends
the very same jokes the very same
behavior may be unifying for us
and to somebody else like my wife or my
a colleague
that may trigger something that happened
when they were a kid and it's and it's
very re-traumatizing right
so I think approaching the world
I've got to
be able to speak my needs out loud
I gotta know when my body is reacting
and I have to be willing to be
hospitable and and humble
I gotta be able to say hey I didn't mean
harm it's probably best if we don't work
together I didn't mean harm anyway I
will never make say that again do that
again make that joke I had no idea I was
neglecting you I I thank you so much for
telling me
consider that problem fixed it's salt
right so I think it's a mix of both
um
here is
um this is from choosingtherapy.com
here's a couple of I'm just going to run
through a couple of different signs that
you may be in an abusive relationship
um
somebody's verbally abusing you they're
swearing at you they're yelling and
screaming at you
and sometimes you can abuse somebody
very very quietly
somebody threatens violence they
threaten to withhold love they were
threaten to withhold food or safety
right verbal abuse
um
some uh
unpredictable behaviors can be abusive
especially for kids when they don't know
what mom or dad they're gonna get well
it's gonna be the rage dad or the drunk
dad or the angry mom or the happy mom or
the super
you know engaged at
their nervous system can never stabilize
it's always toggling with this hard back
and forth between the synthetic and
parasympathetic response it becomes a
mess
um cruelty to animals or others right
um
threatening behavior
forced sexual activity
or disregard for others desire
right you can be abusive through forcing
somebody to cater to your sexual whims
can also be abusive to withhold
connectivity
weaponize it
that can hold somebody hostage
um here's a couple other ones Financial
abuse
dealing money from the joint account
lying about expenses making making
somebody go through you or go through
them in order to spend money I've heard
of couples who somebody gives the other
person an allowance they got to run
every expense by you or you don't have
your own debit card or whatever
or they have their own account right
there's Financial abuse
um they're taking out credit cards in
your name and spending money and racking
up debt that you've got to pay right so
um there's public shaming there's
harassment there's bruises and black
guys and by the way there's the fight or
flight or freeze response when we don't
talk about a lot it's a trauma response
an abuse response is fun
I'm going to nuzzle up to you and get so
close to you
that you won't hit me anymore
I am going to get so close to so it can
look like intimacy
it can look really really close so I
think the key here for me is
anything that makes my body feel like
it's got to protect itself could be
abusive Behavior it's not it's not a
guarantee every time and if anything
that causes my body's sympathetic
nervous system to fire up firefight
ready rock and roll
could be it might not be it might be
that I'm really really tired I took that
the wrong way and that's where it's
incumbent on all of us to learn what we
need
to learn how to regulate our own nervous
systems I can't Outsource that to
everybody I can't make that everybody
that everybody's job that's my job and
if you've experienced trauma that means
you've got some work to do you got some
healing to do that's hard
if you are being abused right now if
you're an abusive relationship
call somebody
call somebody call somebody
[Music]
your life has value outside of being
somebody's punching back
you're worth being loved and you're
worth more than call somebody
reach out to a local hotline if you
don't have a friend or like the last
caller
call some buddies and say it's I need
help come get me
and let's make a plan for what happens
next
Life's too short to be abused
and if you're abusing somebody
[Music]
stop
go get help we'll be right back
it seems so easy but most of us way
undervalue real genuine relationships
our friendships our marriages we don't
know what we're doing and instead of
diving into the mess we accept
shallowness and distraction and we
wallpaper over our loneliness so let me
say this boldly you cannot be well alone
you've got to get connected to real life
people and have deep powerful
relationships I'm talking about
relationships where you can be honest
where you can open up where you can
share hard things and you each know that
you'll still show up for each other and
in my new book own your past change your
future we'll walk through a not so
complicated approach to relationships
mental health and wellness and getting
connected is a key part of that that's
why you'll learn shallowness and
loneliness are so dangerous and more
importantly you'll learn how to create
meaningful relationships in your life
moving forward there is no good app to
help adults find friendships but this
book can help go to John deloney.com to
take the next step towards Wellness
that's own in your past change your
future at John deloney.com
all right as we wrap up today's show
um song of the day is from the great
Alicia Keys
man she's awesome
's called Fallen it goes like this
keep on falling in and out of love with
you sometimes I love you sometimes you
make me blue sometimes I feel good at
times I feel used to love you darling
makes me so confused I keep on falling
in and out of love with you I Never
Loved Someone the way that I love you
that's such a great song
Love's a mess it's hard
best of luck to you we'll see you soon